la rubrica amici da nardò vita buttato
de nardo ciao ragazzi bentornati una
nuova puntata di vita buttata il tema
della puntata di oggi è amici di merda
per un tema così forte ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia una persona che proprio non
potrebbe dirmi nulla
un'amica per non definirla forse sorella
di una vita intera sto parlando
niente poco di meno che di alice che
purtroppo non era presente e 15
tenteremo di camilla ciao ciao a tutti
senti come tanti scusate al preparatore
che comunque petto si è già stata ospite
chiesa dove c'è un momenti chiaro chi
per piacere di essere ospite 1 piacere
al grande piacere ospite di avere occhi
deve davamo fatto tradimenti tradimenti
adesso che ha tirato fuori come le cose
che sarebbe meglio dimenticare mattina
sono sin qui bisogna dire una cosa
camilla è venuta da me anche questo
d'arte che aveva è venuto da me mi ha
chiesto non gli farei dormire a contatto
col divano di pelle ovviamente roeland
solo sopra e questo mi fa chiedere che
tipo di persone conoscano diventano dare
sulla mia umiltà che parlando meno lo
stesso per me è importante la stare
insieme
partiamo subito con l'ascolto dei
messaggi che secondo la cosa migliore
ciao
la mia amica di merda è quella che da
quando avevo 13 anni ha provato tutti i
miei fidanzati
alcune volte ci è riuscita alcune volte
no io intanto l'ho saputo sempre con
molto ritardo però come si dice meglio
tardi che mai
beh che tra l'altro lei anche fanno di
vita buttata quindi se questi audio
arrivassero a lei sarebbe un po la mia b
ditta che va servita fredda cielo
proprio conti stronzetta non si possono
a nome loro ci fosse anche vendetela
potrebbe essere chiunque tu la riconosci
la voce riconoscerei la tua voce brani
milioni di
ma questa è una cosa vera nel mondo
femminile cioè le nostro c'è il figlio
nel mio caso no vabbè non sto parlando
di te ma di una tua amica no neanche una
mia amica se mai permessa di fare una
cosa del genere cosa frenata
il microfono è troppo alto per lei può
vedere lo splendido volto perché se lei
abiti rotondo successo va benissimo
[Musica]
e d'estate a casa nella piscinetta
gonfiabile
chiudete di bloccare in altre otto
l'acqua e ingegneri perché resta basso
al gallo però il bello è stato quando ha
smesso
insomma tutto sommato ancora nessuno sa
dire due morta porte presenterò dovevamo
andare al tribunale di milano e poi si
sarebbe la sede opportuna per analizzare
questo caso però un collega non c'è
stato un gioco che non stavo bene avevo
la diarrea quindi dovevo andare a
prendere una medicina mi ha accompagnato
tanto comunque avevamo un buon rapporto
tra natura il make up come al solito
perché in quella farmacia c'era anche il
metodo era davanti a tutti guarda che
non siamo qui a guardare il mica siamo
qui per prendere a cosa della tua
diarrea ti giuro sono girati tutti si
sono messi a ridere io guardo dovuto non
morire beh potremmo dire amici di merda
ti dice certo che morire avrei voluto
ammazzare che più che morire avrebbe
voluto spruzzarli e massa io devo
parlare delle farmacie
se io vengo da te farmacista e ti dico
ti senti un problema quella diarrea ma
per me ancora è il clistere al doppio
stantuffo devo capire solo io e non agli
altri già mi preme il pulsante del muto
della tastierina quello senza niente da
camera e bluetooth
[Musica]
e non è che dopo averla raccontata del
mio amore platonico durato sei anni tra
i mister sottolinea l'istat ha deciso di
conoscerlo anche davanti a lei c'è un
salvato anche l'africa a lei perché ha
voluto sottolineare regista anche i
rugbisti diciamo sono una sportiva che
interessa molto a questa trasmissione
ah sì sì ma scusate io non siamo questo
canale diventasse siamo molto più se a
te piace uno per sei anni codice
deontologico femminile comunque umano
prevede che tu amico non possa comunque
di carte di m
io tua amica non potrò mai stare male
perché tu me l'hai confidato ecco questo
è un tema molto delicato era se per
avermelo chiesto una persona espinosa
sei comunque un po male pieno di pesci
proprio l'aragosta vibrata parachinar
deciso di raccontarci la figura di merda
che mi ha fatto fare la mia miglior
amica vi sia molta alle giostre erano
sempre al 51 avevamo già stracciato alla
centrale sicurezza per scegliere stavano
parlando nel frattempo lei attaccato
questa cintura di sicurezza una delle
catene che avevano i pantaloni non me
n'ero accorto vado per scendere rimango
canzoni con la catena che mi taglia
praticamente la
e non riuscivo a scendere nel tempo lei
era già giu e se la stava ridendo di
gusto perché la catena che un'italiana
questo lei attaccato al mero stato come
a tutti i bambini penso può capitare di
fare uno score gina in classe
che cosa c'entra non ci parla silenziosa
in maniera tale che nessuno se ne
accorga
bene io ero specialista nel farle
silenziosa e quindi nessuno si è mai
accorto delle mie pompea gas in giorno
proprio nel momento di silenzio tombale
della classe mele sfugge una rumorosa
abbastanza a lungo il controllo del
diaframma noi è l'icona per tutta una
classe meco sul momento nessuno si era
accorto che fossi stata io diciamo a
fare la puzzetta e quindi la terra ha
tremato un momento se non che si sente
una vocina che chiede chi è stato a
questo sussurrare in una prossima
totalmente silenziosa e scioccata per la
scorreggia e provata in classe grandi
amiche anziché diciamo nascondermi dice
chiaro e tondo estate il sabetta cioè io
appunto moglie di imbarazzo di vento
rossa e non volevo detto che non ne
fossi un audio beh io posso dire questa
cosa l'ha mica fatto solo informazioni
ha trovato l'epicentro di questo
terremoto è vero ho deciso in 36 ragazze
la scala richter e quindi non la
possiamo biasimare e poi voglio dire nel
momento in cui te lo chiedono
magari passare io io c'è essere pazzo
una cosa è fatto la ninja fino adesso
sei scivolata durante il tuo percorso
ma ringrazia che è andata buono fino ad
adesso è anche una miracolata milano
attività criminale ciao volevo
raccontare chi no netto successo tra
votandola 17 ramo io i miei vicina
discoteca sottosella rovino la propria
epoca badante sentire arrotino space
scusa mi voleva raccontarti non ne avevo
successo il capodanno 2017 ramos i
tecnici della discoteca e capisci io
capisco capatano coriandoli al 2017
capodanno ma di sicuro sì sì capodanno
2017 vi suona strano stava dando il mio
di solvente bizona più coerenza vicina
discoteca a napoli fa il capo della
mente verso le 5 5 mete del mattino i
cappotti per riuscire in un amico mi fa
veramente male che disse ragazzi mi
aspetto muri vedevo i cappotti
raccomando fate presto nel genio natura
della sua saga ma anche delle cappotti
parte in pezzo della situazione spiaceva
tantissimo e poi seguito a tutti
torniamo potrà dare e gli rimaneva fuori
svenuto per una setta di martina e
ritrova un morto a terra e ci dice degli
amici peggiore che abbiamo avuto con
questo caso siamo noi amici di merda
amici di merda di merda però ai corretti
no però mi è piaciuto che loro hanno
interpretato il tema il contrario che
non hanno raccontato ma si sono
raccontate io mi aspettavo più anche
persone che si mettessero a nudo a nudo
e alla fine c'è questo qui è un luogo
sicuro ma tu puoi dirci quando sei stato
un amico di merda perché se vuoi te lo
dico io quando lo fischia
di merda devo dire questa cosa c'è
proprio quello che ti scrive guarda che
mi tirò giù roma gara ma potesse
colpirmi giunone con un razzo e io la
persona più e dove no ti scrivo
organizza una cena st milano sette mesi
continuativi senza avere niente da fare
voi avete sentito guglielmo io però
anche altre qualità e questo è molto
vero perché io sono una persona
abbastanza
voglio capire come ti definisci
superficiale bravo ti ringrazio per
averlo letto cioè nel senso che io ci
metto la faccia cimentata è
semplicemente il cuore sempre però io
tendo quando tipo mi allontano poi ad
avere problemi a riad per i [ __ ] a
riavvicinarmi a fare cose così è come te
tanto molto nordico che non vedo perchè
fai il tuo hai ragione per questo ti
chiedo scusa
ecco camilla è un'amica di merda perché
no sto cercando un difetto amava i premi
vinti è molto difficile che non avevo re
di ritrovare trovare un difetto camion o
difetti si devono però il rapporto
dell'amicizia esalto infatti nel
rapporto dell'amicizia no parliamo
l'aiuto da casa e molto invadente cioè
non posso dire a milano c'è stata
suggerita io mi sono trovo molto
affettuoso ecco un problema di un
problema di camilla è che da quando si è
fidanzata lei è molto diciamo
concentrata la sua vita poi anche il
fatto che tu da mirandola e monza fa
capire proprio che voi allontanate più
possibile e falso sei falso perché
questo è un ha detto prima veleno di bel
culo andiamo avanti con i messaggi
[Risate]
e comunque quello che lei dice sui neri
ospite i nemici di merda su quelli che
con 14 anni andavamo giocare a calcetto
al parco che il pallone fini dentro un
campo da tennis chiuso da una rete di
tre metri di altezza
io mi sono offerta di scavalcarla grazie
a un albero che solo dopo una volta
dentro mi sono reso conto che non ci
fosse all'interno che una volta passato
il pallone per avere le mani libere nel
tentativo difficoltoso di scavalcare
questi tre metri loro melanzane un
pallone contro la rete credendo guardate
l'uomo jaguar in trappola coloro dopo
sono diventati a chi metri stile libero
live again
ma questa era un'altra preoccupante ma
non è stato un atto di bullismo è stato
un momento di amicizia moltiplicazione è
una prova l'idea merati smo cameratismo
se vedete questo video camera grazie
mille per esserci stato e per esistere
grazie di esistere io sono la cerata io
ti ho visto che sei entrata con uno
sguardo ma adesso ne ha un altro un
altro che non ho neanche più il
bigliettino mi ha costretto vuol dire
che è stato veramente un bel momento è
un bel momento che mi ricorderò grazie a
questo video che andrà online si
prossimamente sui canali anche perché
ci rivediamo naturalmente se sei mesi
sono milanista comunque che ho mostrato
la mia generosità
certo è che non è mai messo in dubbio
mai questo dice che ha creato un credito
nei due confronti che tu ti puoi
spendere
no no alle aste non ebbe però di aver
tolto il mio credito
ok il difetto mio difetto non è affetto
noi come sempre ci vediamo questa
domenica
se vi è piaciuto non so come chiuderlo
ti mando un bacio ciao ciao